..for treason by the
Knight's court
in the French town
of Larroquette,
I watched as my mentor,
the Marquis Post's head
rolled from the guillotine
to my very feet,
thinking, "This has ruined
a perfectly good opera."
Lillian, this afternoon
was so pleasant.
We'd love to induct you
as a fully vetted member
of Newport's very own
Clam Bake Club.
Are you familiar
with our organization?
Am I familiar
with your organization?
It's only the most prestigious
mollusk-based social group
in all of North America.
We put those insufferable
dunderpates
in the Portsmouth
Scallop Society to shame.
I would love to finger clams
with you two.
Well, then,
looking forward to it.
Doors.
[vocalizing]
[upbeat music]
♪ I knew it all along ♪
♪ This is my destiny ♪
♪ I finally have it all ♪
♪ And no one
deserves it more than me ♪
♪ The bottom 1% of the top 1% ♪
♪ Is the loneliest place
for a girl ♪
♪ But I'm the piece of sand
who's gonna irritate the clam ♪
♪ Until I turn into a pearl ♪
♪ I was on the outside,
now I'm not ♪
♪ It's time to show Newport
what I've got ♪
♪ See this face?
You're gonna see it a lot ♪
♪ It's exactly
where I was meant to be ♪
♪ I can finally say ♪
♪ "Hi, society" ♪
♪ The bottom 1%
of the bottom 1%
♪ Is just fine with me ♪
♪ Because I got a letter and my
life will get much better ♪
- ♪ When I work at a factory ♪
- Hey!
♪ I thought it was hopeless
I was wrong ♪
Get out of the way, Blanche!
This is my song!
[vocalizing]
Well, now I forgot
what I was even singing about.
[groans]
You're all fired!